joining me here on this show look I kind
of wanted to have this guy on because I
love talking to him but I also love him
I love him like a family member my kids
call him uncle Michael he was at my
wedding he was at my daughter's
baby-naming this man his family and
since there's so much conversation about
what's going on in the world between
white and black and brown and black and
white and brown I wanted to have this
guy on and just talk about life in
general and also for the lack of a
better phrase model what I think should
be going on in this world I love this
man I love you Michael Irvin thank you
for calling in to this show today thanks
Rachel how are you guys doing I missed
all of all of this rich and rich even
just that introduction kind of talked up
talks about where we are you know and
this whole situation has been for us as
a country and certainly for us as as a
people a hell of an emotional
rollercoaster I mean a house to come off
three months of showing solidarity and
common ground to beat this invisible
devil that we call Cove in nineteen Matt
right into this situation where after
showing unity now fighting each other
are perceived to be fighting each other
and we'll talk about that as a race it's
just insane it's insane what we've been
going through rich it really is that's a
good way to I guess start this Michael
because I always viewed and I was saying
here about you know social distancing
then what that phrase means but what it
also sounds like and seeing the streets
empty and staying at home and not having
human contact with each other and how
difficult that has been for so many
people who are you know in danger of
getting kovat 19 folks also like my mom
who's 82 lost her husband of 50-plus
years just at the outset of this and
being alone and how difficult that is
for so many people that I was sitting
here on this
Michael and say you know I look at the
empty streets I look at the empty lives
and I say that that is actually a sign
of coming together that we're all doing
the same thing to come together as one
interesting that that you would say that
that that that what just when we're all
living in that and and and and basking
in it as we should this happens right
and I say that because you know I I have
to try to put sense to it i overthink
everything it'll analyze everything and
you just you know when we saw that when
we saw that man I was like I was amazed
I was amazed at everybody coming out
everybody's speaking about how important
it is that we do the right thing and
then I am equally amazed this in Indy
the drawing away of the security or the
fight and Koba 19 and coming out because
wait a minute this is as great a threat
to us as the cold at 19 BC people in
crowds like they are in clouds now
coming off three months which not not
being around anybody you're throwing all
of that in the wind and and that's what
that that I feel good about that
everybody said wait a minute this is
that's dangerous this right here this
racism this kind of stuff coming from
that place and and headed towards that
place coming from the police towards
half camera is it dangerous if the Pope
at 19 and we're skirting everything to
say enough is enough I don't try to put
it together I kind of said to myself
this is kind of this we are in the midst
of the pain that comes in the process
towards progress you know the ugly has
to be shown the ugly has to be shown and
we've seen the ugly in the Audrey case
you know with with with with the
Gregory's Timothy Gregory and with
Gregory we felt we saw that man get shot
just jogging and then we see the ugly of
Dara shavon sitting on this man's neck
sitting
this man's neck as he cries out for help
so you see that kind of stuff man you
said oh my god oh my god where are we as
a country but to see all of these people
come together rich all of these people
come and say enough is enough
yeah it's pain to see all of that but
that's progress that's progress but now
people are starting to hear what we as
African Americans have been saying for
quite a while and a lot of times this
kind
I'd only said fell on deaf ears when you
hear people say the systemic racism it's
because it's in higher places the RV
case with the Michaels they were in
charge is because it went to a
prosecutor named Barnhill who was three
years with the McMichaels he had to
recuse himself and as he reaches himself
he left a letter to the next prosecutor
to say I don't think they did anything
wrong you see what I'm saying we get the
issues that happen on the street because
they know they're protected by some
people that have that that are not clean
and salt and not clean and right and
higher positions that will protect them
we can't just get the police officers
without getting those higher people that
have been protecting them out before we
go for Michael Irvin here on the Rich
Eisen show what do you want people to
know Michael I'm just gonna just a very
hugely open-ended question but
understand yeah we're in pain now
there's been great progress and we're
going to see more progress now now now
things will start changing and to that I
have to thank all of the other people
that are not people of color that were
in the fight before and and and now I
have to thank all of the other people
that are not people of color that I said
wait a minute and I've started joining
the fight I've started joining the fight
and that's what we're seeing in the
streets of all of these cities we're
seeing all of these people say how can I
be a human and see this and be okay
where
this and and and this is not right so I
thank them for coming up and that
touches me all so rich that that's why
right that's why I defend all of you
guys that Texas and I don't mind I'll
share this here because we see all of
that and and I want to make sure that
doesn't affect where we are and I want
people to always understand there's
progress being made like we have a great
we have great friendships great working
relationships we're all living each each
other's lives and I think that takes all
the people that I work with just to say
hey thank you it has been crystallized
with all this going on in this country
right now how blessed I am to be walking
my life out and working with men such
great man a great character and great
heart because we see the other people
are out there too the other people are
out there and I just wanted you guys to
know how much I appreciate who you are
but we gotta get those other people out
there out of here
Michael Irvin here on the Rich Eisen
show and then it's you know our own
house in the NFL that is now front and
center in statements that have just been
made in the last 24 hours the coach of
Denver and Vic Fangio as he gave a
full-throated support for what is
happening in the streets for George
Floyd and trying to protest against
police brutality he said that there
should be files of charges of treason
treason filed against the the cop who
murdered there's that's my word
George Floyd on the streets of
Minneapolis but he also said he didn't
see any racism in the NFL talking about
there's a meritocracy here in the NFL
and then moments ago Drew Brees on Yahoo
being interviewed with the prospect of
maybe players kneeling during the
national anthem again him saying that he
doesn't agree with anybody who
disrespect disrespects the United States
flag and then went on a very full
throated reason as to why and people who
who have fought for the country and
fought for the right for for protests
there's going to be a lot of recruitment
and finger pointing going on Michael and
I'm wondering what you could you know
say about all that well to that point
you know Andrew listen I I respect all
the people in the hope for this country
but the reality is the reality is and
let's just go to the point go to the
source when Colin Kapernick took that
knee he was not doing it and and to
disrespect the people that a fault for
this country it was actually happened he
had talked to someone that had fought
for the country they told me I'm gonna
take the NEET yes so so he was not doing
that but what what remains that should
be shocking is that it's the same it's
the same poles that killed Floyd it's
the same pose that killed Floyd so so so
even some of the people like Drew Brees
who who may have it felt emotionally one
way we're on when they see this video
cuz I watch you go on to new york times
they put together a watch but yes you
have to see it it's a great piece it's a
great piece of that you see everything
man when you see that you're like oh my
god that's murder that's murder industry
there was no reform for $20 he's gonna
think $20 or whatever that there's no
reason that should have come to that is
there's no reason it should have come to
that and I just I just I feel badly for
but all of those people that saw that
and believe values justice countries
against this country it's okay to come
across now and say now I see let's not
be so you know rigid there's not be so
rigid
into who we are in our beliefs that we
don't come across the water now and say
you know what I was wrong I see I see
what it was about now and I want to give
a hand to helping out and a lot of
people have said that he said it to me
so so I just want to thank all of those
people for putting down their ego and
coming across this and no we gotta stop
this and I think you see a lot of those
people all throughout the streets
throughout this country Michael Irvin
you're on the Rich Eisen show and I also
do want to bring this up to with you
because I've seen you uh I've seen you
on the sidelines you're a popular guy um
the the number of folks at law
enforcement that come up to you and you
have conversations with them and people
you know in the law enforcement and I'm
sure you had that's what makes it
difficult rich it's not it we're not
talking about everybody there's so many
limitations we need law enforcement we
need law enforcement for our protection
what we do not need is black men being
persecuted and executed a great number
of great people out here do their jobs
and do it well you know in doing what I
you know but we we got to stop the
persecution and certainly the execution
the persecution right I can tell you
over the last few months I bet I've been
stalked a couple of times I even soon I
said well my guys stopped riding and
driving in Addison Texas here's registry
and I was just driving around and a guy
he stopped me yeah because III did a
u-turn to go back by the park everybody
was just starting to come back out you
trying to go back by the park to see
people out I was just driving around
such as three people and and cars came
up I said why are you stopping me I
didn't do anything wrong
he said well you were in a training and
didn't turn on your train signal so I
turn but I was in the turning lane you
know the turning lane anyway he finally
broke down and said okay okay Michael
when he found out who it was he said oh
really we have a phone call from people
that said there was a suspicious black
man in the g-wagon driving around you
know so we have to change the mentality
the mentality or the lady in the park
that's their own about that but but
that's the mentality all those man tell
those people with that mentality that
those are people that they're finding
they're going to jewelry then that all
police officers that do wrong that's the
systemic issue that we have that
perpetuates itself that we got to root
out of this country a lot of great
people and I know rich and I apologize
to all of the great people out there to
do the right thing
they get sucked into these two people
that are of debt that that really are
filed and are doing the wrong thing I
apologize to all of your eyes and I
think everybody for coming out and
getting in this fight like we are seeing
in this country exactly and and for
people who who may you know need to hear
this you know if you look and wonder why
people are protesting and hopefully
peacefully in a peaceable manner it's
because maybe they don't get pulled over
because the color of their skin is not
cause someone to call the cops or the
reason why that somebody who has the
color of skin that causes something to
cause the cops that doesn't have an
escalating situation happen is because
they don't have the resume of Michael
Irvin and the name recognition in facial
recognition and this is something that
needs to be talked about and it has to
be talked about and rectified and it has
to be brought in a manner again I've got
a Anquan Boldin on tomorrow's show in a
way where state houses need to be
involved and courthouses need to be
involved and change needs to happen from
people who are understanding or wanting
to understand this and I think it's
important to say that I just wanted to
say that right in those positions to
make those changes and not just at the
police level because they're the police
hey I got so comfortable enough to lay
on this man's neck for nine minutes it
was almost as if he knew everybody
filming she saw this man go limp and it
was homeless if he's thinking I'm going
to get a poems for the locker room to
put in my KKK meeting he knew this was
being taken and you worked and he would
not come off that man's neck that's in
saying that is insane
that you so comfortable enough to openly
do this murder on tape or on film and
filaria you know I just want to be no
repercussions he dared you thinking
there will be no repercussions so we
have to root out the problem above about
the officers not just officers you know
I started to post that last couple times
when I got stopped because I jumped at
all I started to post it you know I did
post a rich I called a friend of mine
and he's an African American and he's a
trooper here in Dallas and I was telling
him about that's a man I'm thinking
about posting it he said Mike he said
let me just explain to you or whatever
he said first of all he said you know
you voted and if people see the officer
and he's branded maybe he's branded a
racist or something like that when the
reality is in that situation he may not
be he was just answering the call yes
answer the call yes his job he has to
answer the call and that made me not
post it but maybe also think okay so the
issue eyes deeper than that the issue
eyes with the people that I even above
them that we have to think up the issue
rise with the people that with us the
peers because when we ultimately go to
court and you look at the list of
officers that have gotten off over the
last ten years of things even against
that we've seen happen live you're off
on those cases you know the jury pool
it's coming from all of us so we have to
change the way we see all of those
things man it's an insane undertaking
that we have to start walking Michael
Irvin here on the show you know and so
now I know that when you come to Los
Angeles and you drive to work you're
taking a step down from that g-wagen
with the rentals that you're getting
Michael
[Music]
[Music]
like I got a Hummer here I won't even
drive it away every time every time I
Drive this white god brother doubt our
Hummer I hip or don't come on every and
I mess with him I said come on man you
have to stop stopping minutes go I said
never want to drive anymore I just leave
you at home and he said to me sir my
client I didn't even know you had a
white when I thought you had a black
would if it was black I painted a white
how are you watching me too closely
these clothes we have to get to the
issue because we did that to Bob just
the officers and at that level before I
let you go Michael let's just talk a
couple minutes of sports here what do
you say to people that say dak doesn't
deserve the money meaning Chris Brockman
what do you say what do you say that dak
doesn't deserve to get 35 40 million
bucks a year and that and that if he
does get it he's gonna cap string the
the I guess hamstring via the cap the
the Cowboys for years to come well
problem has persisted and it we've been
going down this road for quite a while
the quarterback whoever he's up we've
always argued about this Ridge when we
see Kirk Cousins all of these guys get
the money and get Jimmy Garoppolo got
the money he got for six or seven games
played the money we just got basically
all through here so this has been the
business of the quarterback position and
that has done everything he has won he
has won a lot of football games in his
first four years so to say that deserves
our money isn't totally correct he does
deserve the money that's the market and
he's our starting winning quarterback in
this NFL it's just a matter of getting
it done you know and I think they'll get
it done it's business that one at once
every penny and Julie wants to try to
save every penny yeah but but mostly
these are those kinds of deals I always
tell people will get done soon as the
slip will fall off Cinderella 12:01
12:01
something will get done and it'll come
in and that'll be for a moment very
Court of that before Pat mahomes get
here
I just find it funny that it's it's all
Garrett's fault and then Garrett's gone
now it's Jack's fault you know what I'm
saying like that that that that if
everybody who thinks it was Jason
Garrett's fault and we all know Garrett
is it has been a fall guy in many ways
well and many reasons you know what you
know a lot of the you know do I go for
it do I not didn't know when the punt
didn't know when to go for it you know
that a lot of the problems that were
laid at his feet
whether rightful are wrong but they were
laid at his feet now that he's not there
it's not like so we're paying dak for
going eight Nate in a season where we
were blaming the coach the entire time
right so now you know that statistically
puts up his best year we're usually you
know people you put up number I thought
that's what this generation was more
about numbers instead of Championships
you know but but always whenever there
is a dispute between player and
organization people always get on the
player they always get on the player
that has been not not great not great
that has been perfect of course but I'm
talking about just the person that he's
been the kind of the kind of investment
you want to make the counterpoint the
kind of guy you said man we hit it we
hit it with this guy we got him in the
fourth round so you stole four years you
stole for you so whatever you get he
deserves because you still own them back
pay and he also pledged a million
dollars to improve police training and
address systemic racism in America today
I love the guy I love the can know that
but if I mean that's a group moves by
him and now all he does is set of Ages
he tell you we want 41 million
[Applause]
41 I love your I love you michael irvin
best to your family and everybody from
me and Sue's and all of our state oh my
kids say hello to Uncle Michael you take
care of yourself chat soon I appreciate
your age and I mean everything yes the
last thing I want to say reaches I don't
want us to see all this unrest and
forget about all of the great progress
and continue to make progress together
we'll get out all of these bad apples
and make it a great place all right or
if you take care of we'll chat soon chat
soon hey thanks buddy
Michael Irvin the one and only got
Michael Irvin 88